[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
i wouldn't count her out just quite yet
these polls have not been
spot on
you just look at kansas and a few other
these races
i don't know that she is down and out
yet
the good news is is it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter if liz cheney wins or
loses
it doesn't it doesn't really matter
because she's still going to be the
congresswoman from wyoming that is
absolutely
carrying the shovel that will that will
dig donald trump's political grave
that's the most important thing even
after she's a congresswoman
she will still be the one trying to make
sure to destroy trumpism she wants her
party back and what i mean by that is
darth vader jr as you know i refer to
her here liz cheney
absolutely wants to be the leader of the
old guard
the g.o.p not the gqp
she's made that clear
it's obvious
even when she gets dick cheney darth
vader himself to make a video to
convince
the citizens of wyoming to
pluck their head out of their ass
and what better timing
what better timing
did he say he's the biggest crook who's
ever i don't remember exactly what he
said maybe we'll find the video
the biggest crook to ever get in the
white house
the biggest criminal
and you have grandpa poopy pants the
cheeto dust mobster
the orange mussolini jesus himself
whining and crying he can't he can't
stop bitching about about this search
warrant he can't stop bitching that they
went and
they're gonna find out his crimes he
can't stop with the [ __ ] throwing the
ketchup on the wall and [ __ ] it's like a
little [ __ ] kid in the grocery store
you ever seen this throwing himself on
the floor
you know in the old days they'd pick you
up by your wrist and they'd give you
about five swats on the ass before they
threw you in the cart
that's the old days
nowadays we don't do that anymore
we just don't
well some folks do
maybe that's what happened to donald
trump maybe he never got the five swats
he probably never got put in the grocery
store to be quite honest with you
uh donald trump jr made a video
oh [ __ ] i'm not [ __ ] you
old booger sugar junior is now and now
vocal
about the crimes that donald trump is
gonna be indicted on
it's unfair it's unfair my daddy my
daddy he's gonna go to jail
and we're gonna be broke i think that's
the the crux of it well we'll get into
the donald trump jr video today we also
have texas paul it's tuesday folks and
it's not just taco tuesday
it's texas paul tuesday we have texas
paul here at the bottom of the hour
we never got a chance because the beto
[ __ ]
or the [ __ ] beto video you know
what i'm talking about where beto calls
the abbott supporter of [ __ ]
because he's laughing
at the fact that 19 children got
slaughtered in uvalde by a weapon of war
he's laughing at it
and beto points out and says that's not
funny [ __ ]
so we never got a chance that that that
and piece of news fell in the cycle
between last tuesday and this tuesday so
we're gonna talk about it today we're
gonna get texas paul's thoughts live on
the air at the bottom of the hour
so stay tuned
at the bottom of the hour we'll bring
texas paul in and get his
his take on the beto video and really
where betto's at in this race because i
think that's more important than just
the the him calling out amit supporters
where he's at in this race i think is
important as well
so stay tuned at the bottom of the iron
texas paul the midas mighty
favorite will join us
if you're not following the minus touch
network you should
they bring breaking news clips
from all the news that is happening
around the world right to you right on
right in a digestible way
on youtube
twitter
and facebook
you know we broadcast every single
weekday we're more of a long-form show
as you know we do two hours two hours
every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific on youtube twitter and twitch
and we simulcast from the midas touch
facebook page welcome all you books of
facers
welcome to the new audience members our
audience has been growing and growing
you guys must be telling all your family
and friends
about the [ __ ] fam here on the tony
michaels podcast come to youtube come to
the live chat have fun with all your
friends
here at the [ __ ] fam there's also a
chat that goes on over on facebook you
guys are really lively on facebook and
twitch as well
twitter is a little different story when
we broadcast over there because it used
to be periscope
and those comments used to stick to come
through like we could see those comments
but you they don't go anywhere now
twitter took over periscope and they
kind of got rid of it sorta they did it
internally
they kept the same platform but they
didn't push out the stuff that they push
out so twitter
is just not the same since periscope
went down and twitter's been doing it
internally as opposed to leaning on
periscope to do that
so it's a little different over there so
if you want to get involved in a live
chat
come over to youtube or if you have if
you have a books of face account
you can go over to the midas touch
facebook page we broadcast from there we
also
we also download every single episode on
your favorite directory
apple spotify google wherever you
download your podcast make sure to go
and give us a great review and download
every single podcast you might as well
listen to us
i mean the the nice nice part about the
the directories is you can put it in
like time and a half time and three
quarters or two times the speed
so you can really get a sense
of how fast i talk or don't talk
whichever you you prefer
there so if you don't like looking at my
beautiful face you can go listen to my
beautiful voice over on the directories
don't forget to also follow us on
twitter at tonymichaelspod
where you can vote every single week for
bonehead of the week but also we do all
the shows over there
we send all the promos out
so check that out we also put some
satire clips over on the uh the tony
michaels pod page
on twitter also subscribe here
on youtube the tony michaels podcast
don't forget to do that and you can see
we have a new link down at the bottom of
the broadcast here to support
pro-democracy speech you can use the qr
code or the link support dot
tonymichaelspod.com
where you can support pro-democracy
speech today don't forget to go do that
and we thank all the new listeners we
thank all the supporters out there that
we have
we could not do this without you without
you we could not broadcast two hours a
day everyone's been saying we should do
three hours a day
and i would love to do three hours a day
it's a lot of time but we could do three
hours a day we would just we would need
just a bit more
just a bit more to get to three hours
it cost
us time and money but we could do it we
could do it we could get the audience so
invite your friends your family the
people that you talk to on social media
invite them over here get them to come
watch live or watch the show after it
airs on youtube or go download it we had
we've had record-breaking numbers
now this week so far with downloads and
views
thank you thank you very very much and i
also want to thank i have a special
thank you for our moderators
in the youtube chat our moderators midas
robin and mj
in the in in the youtube chat
torching torching the awful trolls
so thank you mj and thank you midas
robin
for
sticking with us and kicking kicking ass
and taking names in the chat there and
keeping everyone comfy
in the live chat
again don't forget
don't forget
to go over to the youtube page if you're
not here already
and participate in that live chat and
subscribe
click subscribe put your bell
notification you do not want to miss a
single
video
liz cheney is she going to win i guess
that's the question this morning it's
tuesday it's a primary it looks like
sarah palin is gonna be the republican
nominee
for
uh alaska's congressperson um in alaska
it looks like liz cheney may lose that's
what the polls are saying i don't trust
the polls do you trust the bulls i don't
trust the polls this year to be quite
honest with you they haven't been very
reliable so far
they have not
hmm
if you look at kansas right
that referendum about women's bodily
autonomy that was supposed
to pass with a yes vote and women and
the
citizens of kansas said no [ __ ] you
cannot have my bodily autonomy
the polls
were off
we've seen the polls off in several
other places that just didn't compute so
i don't really trust that the polls in
wyoming are exactly spot on the other
evidence that is coming out of wyoming
more and more as we get closer and
closer to this primary as today's
primary day in wyoming
is we
we find more and more democrats switch
their registration to republican just to
vote for liz cheney in the primary
i think i think
pro-democracy people
pro-democracy people
right
and it's not always just because you
affiliate with the democratic party but
in today's age there's only one party
that is for democracy only one
we live in a two-party system two-party
democratic system where only one party
believes in democracy it's kind of
[ __ ] weird that's really the trouble
that we're having
i mean there's several people in the
republican party that are okay with
democracy liz cheney being one that
tolerates democracy you know it's an end
to a means of her power
but in wyoming i think pro-democracy
people see
the writing on the wall and they know
that this weirdo this election fraud
portrayer
the the the election denier who is her
opponent i don't i don't even remember
her name
it's kind of funky of course she's a
trump supporter trump supporters are
funky they're funky right
it's weird it's weird they wear they
wear weird clothes they look they have a
weird costume i mean it's just it's
[ __ ] weird
it's [ __ ] weird
but here's the thing
i believe that pro-democracy people in
wyoming now
grant it in wyoming
that republicans outnumber democrats
like like four to one okay or three to
one or something like that the numbers
are stacked against democrats in wyoming
in the first place
but
but here's the thing and here's the big
big huge but
big huge smelly but
is that i don't believe that all the
republicans in wyoming
are are against democracy
i believe that's why liz cheney decided
that she would stick around
for democracy for a bit and she she
turned on donald trump the same way dick
cheney basically eviscerated donald
trump and his ad
for liz cheney
right
so i'm not sure i'm not sure
if if wyoming
if every single republican in wyoming
is going to
absolutely
mark the ballot against liz cheney just
because she has torched donald trump
i don't know if i believe that yet
i have a sneaking suspicion that she's
going to lose but i have a feeling it's
going to be a hell of a lot closer and a
hell of a lot tighter race than what the
polls are portraying and the reason why
is because of pro-democracy people which
mainly democrats but if there are some
republicans who watched what happened on
january 6 in wyoming get out and
actually vote and engage in the ballot
the way that we talk about all over the
country
now i believe i believe liz cheney still
has a shot in wyoming this idea that she
does not have a does not have a shot i
think is really kind of ridiculous and i
think it's more of the media playing up
the sensationalism of a [ __ ] pole
and not giving not giving the benefit of
the doubt to people who love democracy
regardless of their party affiliation
because i think we know that better than
anyone here on the tony michaels podcast
we have a lot of people who are former
republicans who consider themselves even
conservative at this point
who are pro-democracy who are not going
to vote for republicans who are not
going to let these fascists the gqp the
trumplinites the maglinites take over
our country and turn it into the fascist
state that ron desantis has the example
of in florida
where he's banning book fairs what the
actual [ __ ]
i mean
they want to talk about all kinds of
[ __ ] about ron desantis
but think about this he's banning
[ __ ] book fairs folks what in the
[ __ ]
what the hell is going on
so this idea this idea that somehow
liz cheney doesn't have a shot in
wyoming that people in wyoming just are
so disconnected
i think
i don't know that i'd go that far quite
yet
now again i have a crystal ball right
doubt me
i'm still not all in that she's going to
win it's going to be close no matter how
you shake it i think it's going to be
close and i may be wrong here
but what do i have to lose here because
really honestly
i'm not a delicious cheney fan
everyone you know sycophants over her
but listen this is a risky business here
in politics you know that we have
two sides of politics we have the
election the politics side where you
play politics and then you have actual
government right where you set policy
those are two separate things
winning an election and running an
election is totally different than
actually doing policy completely
different and liz cheney can act like
she's for government she's for democracy
she's against trump and her campaign
effort but listen on the policy side of
it folks liz cheney votes every single
time
every single time with him
every [ __ ] time she votes with
him okay
so just because we want her to win an
election
so she can keep dunking on trump as a
congresswoman doesn't mean we agree with
her policy
we don't have to agree with her policy
and her policy sucks
it's horrible it's [ __ ] horrible her
policy is absolutely horrible
no matter how you shake it no matter
what you do no matter one thing one
little if you take if you take same-sex
marriage and you pick that out just
just taking one or two things it still
does not negate that liz cheney 95 of
the time is gonna vote in a vile way
and that's risky business
so actually i believe that if liz cheney
wins her race in wyoming
i believe i believe it makes her
much more powerful in the house
especially when we get trumpism to crawl
back underneath its rock now it may take
a bit if she loses the race
if she loses the race in wyoming not
only do we not have liz cheney that
darth vader junior
now dark cheney as you've seen from our
thumbnail today activate dark genie
a play on the dark on the on the dark
dark brandon thing um
darth vader jr liz cheney if she loses
is poised to run
for president in 2024 now i'm not saying
that that you know we're so far out from
that
but listen
what i am saying is that a liz cheney
regime rather it be in the house rather
be in any any kind of branch of
government especially the executive
branch a liz cheney regime would not be
a regime that pro-democracy people would
enjoy it would not be
it won't be she wants she is not for
voting right she is not for women's
rights this is all this is all uh really
just a show so that we keep the shovel
in liz cheney's hand as she digs the
grave for trumpism
kind of the enemy of my enemy is my
friend type thing so remember that
remember that going forward and when you
hear this news about liz cheney
today whether she wins or she loses and
it might be tomorrow morning before we
know but uh likely we'll hear tonight
sometime tonight early tomorrow morning
of rather liz cheney won her race unless
it's very very close if it's very very
close her opponent is likely to call
fraud and it was all red
all this [ __ ]
so listen
do not count
dark cheney out
dark cheney
is going is going to put up a hell of a
fight here one way or the other
one way or another is going to put up a
fight speaking of fights uh dr oz is
losing badly in in pennsylvania as you
know um and more it gets worse and worse
for dr oz and the reason why is because
the grocery store video has been you
know circulating around this wagner
where he's he's talking about making
some kind of [ __ ] i don't know what
the hell it's called i don't know
i eat hot dogs and macaroni and cheese i
don't understand why this guy thought it
was a good idea to talk about
some kind of crazy dish
so i i don't know i'm not really sure
i don't know
i don't know but here's the thing
here's the thing
dr oz
is a phony he's fake
but in that video he's being a little
sincere when he's you know
looking down his nose with others who
shop for
hot dogs and macaroni and cheese at the
grocery store i don't understand why dr
oz wouldn't went to the frozen pizza
aisle think about this
think about this for a second dr oz
would have been much better off if he
would have went to the frozen peeps
aisle and talked about how frozen pizzas
would have been more expensive you know
you know in pennsylvania the trump
lodites the mycolonites eat a shitload
of frozen pizza i like frozen pizza i'm
not saying i don't like frozen pizza i'm
not talking down to anybody i love
frozen pizza
as a matter of fact
i like lunch meat sandwiches anyone else
like baloney oh i wish i was an oscar
meyer wiener i'm just telling you that
look the reason why jon fetterman is
winning is because if anything jon
fetterman is running the hot dog
campaign
okay philly cheesesteak
campaign
and oz is running the i don't know
fancy fancy food feast
campaign
what in the [ __ ] is wrong with this guy
and that that video is old that's the
craziest part is that video is old
it's old well look some people are
saying that that
that
that trumpers don't eat vegetables i i
got gabe sanchez which is rare here in
the first the first first 30 minutes
gabe sanchez
is joining us gabe how are you i'm good
how are you people are saying that
trumpers in pennsylvania don't eat
vegetables i don't think that's correct
i don't think they eat vegetables the
way that dr oz thinks that they eat
vegetables i'm going to say i watched
that video and that was the weirdest
thing i've ever seen like you come in
that's an old video though that's an old
video it's been around for a while
really yeah oh yeah it's been around for
a while i watched that a
month ago a month ago and it's just
resurfacing huh i did not know that that
that's uh oh yeah well i can tell you
this much the fact that he says like
look i'm gonna make a crew data and uh
i'm out here at wegner's with what what
is it what is it
what a crew data what the [ __ ] is that i
don't even know what that is it's a
platter of vegetables
what
oh so why didn't he say a vegetable tree
why didn't he say that it's i don't know
i don't know i mean like he's trying to
sound fancy but oh so i get i okay now i
see what this is now i see what this is
okay okay so i get it i get it yeah i
know what the hell that was i didn't
even look it up i didn't even look it up
because i was like what the [ __ ] is that
[ __ ] he combined two there's like
redners and wagner and uh what was the
other one and so he didn't even say the
grocery store right that's why people
are pissed off right right yeah yeah
right so
well hey wait but the clip is old and
then i think that's why people did this
is because they noticed that he said it
wrong
they didn't notice that when it first
released oh maybe or the fact that it
seems like the rnc is pulling funding
for advertising for him and they're like
let's just [ __ ] pile on here so i
didn't even know that was i didn't know
that was old i thought that was recent
oh but like i don't know i i said i was
like well i guess if there's any kind of
consolation prize here right the the
silver lining is that he taught people
how not to make a crew detail which
again it's you know it's a platter of
vegetables you have dips you know
but what he made or what he was trying
to make he's like oh yeah we'll get some
asparagus not in a coup d'etat carrots
yeah sure i didn't know i didn't know if
he was making like a shake or what the
hell this guy's no no no and he's got
broccoli totally fine but then
he's like let me get some guacamole okay
you know a stretch but that might be
something that people want fine and then
he says salsa and i was like
what the [ __ ] is this this is the
vegetables who dips vegetables and salsa
gabe i yeah what the [ __ ] look if you're
a fan of wait now wait listen listen
this is taco tuesday and we know that
gabe sanchez is a taco connoisseur now
this now salsa a lot of times ends up on
tacos if i'm not mistaken now here's the
thing here's the thing i am actually
more offended now talking to you about
this video than i was when i originally
seen it way back when and i thought what
the [ __ ] is this i don't know i didn't
know what the hell he was talking about
i thought it was like was making some
kind of a vegetable shake or some [ __ ] i
didn't no no not at all i mean you yeah
i mean like those items i guess you
could put in a vegetable i mean carrots
yeah broccoli sure asparagus an
interesting choice for a shake but you
know i think you're saying it wrong
aaron aaron has the uh
cootie tay pretty tay well because
crude tot really sounds very similar to
kudai thai yeah maybe i'm thinking maybe
maybe maybe you're mixing
and
cooking yeah crude crew detail
yeah maybe you know what i think i've
spent so much time embedded within this
fashion history we're trying to pull off
a coup d'etat oh my god jesus so
apologies for me mispronouncing my head
has been elsewhere aaron aaron from
facebook thank you for correcting um
but what i will say
is that uh
it really taught people how not to make
one right like he was like here are the
ingredients which again it's just a
fancy way of saying here's a vegetable
platter you could buy them
i always have a coup on my brain you
know always i'm always thinking you know
candace says gabe has coo on the brain
well i mean it's hard to not when the
the news cycle is all but cool
right
so but uh
yeah and
this video old and i i don't care it
still shows how out of touch dr oz is to
one he just shows up to the to the uh
produce aisle and he's like all right
i'm gonna get some vegetables and he
starts just
holding the vegetables you know that
brings up a good point why would you get
the big carrots why wouldn't you get a
bag of baby carrots if you were gonna
have a dipping tray i never thought of
it that way what the other way that you
could do is you could take the carrot
and you can cut it up and then cut them
into wedges so you could do it that way
right i mean baby can you ever see the
baby here
yeah but here's the thing here's the
thing
most folks most working people who don't
have the time to [ __ ] around with
cutting carrots in the wedges gabe most
most working class people go into the
grocery store
and they go to like the dipping section
there's like cheese there's all kinds of
different and there's a big [ __ ] tray
with the vegetables and all these yeah
there's a plastic you just peel the
whole plastic just take the [ __ ]
and buy a whole thing a party platter
take it home open the [ __ ] lid bam
there's your coup d'etat i mean you're
created
there's your there's your your couplet
your coup platter just know there's an
accent over the e
okay i got you well here's the
here's the problem is
is that um i don't think most people
knew what the [ __ ] that was and what he
was making and you're right asparagus is
way off the mark he totally just walked
up to the vegetables they're like oh
would you say you're gonna make a
vegetable tray he's like vegetables
right what is that simple like what is a
vegetable tray and he's like oh you mean
a critite and they're like yeah he's
like oh okay yeah sure so he just starts
grabbing things right i mean it's also
something like if you've ever had like a
charcuterie right that's like
same kind of family of things where it's
like oh i'll you know i'll throw in this
i've heard this i've heard this term
yeah you know here in the midwest here
in the midwest here in the midwest we
just yeah but it's the same snacks
in the same sense it's just a tray of
items that you snack eating cheese you
got dips you got cheeses you got
vegetables
you know charcuterie add some add some
meats to there yeah well
again the problem is the problem is is
that
that
these these fancy words are the things
that are going to make dr oz loose yeah
definitely because it's obvious that
he's out of touch here he's just not in
touch with what exactly is
i guarantee that dr oz does not do his
own shopping
and as a result
this was the first time he's probably
been in a grocery store in
because i think that's that i think
that's why it resurfaces because
he said wagner's and that's not a
grocery store in pennsylvania
um it's like you said it's a combo of
two stores so he's confusing two stores
and i think i don't know what stores
it's kroger and something else is what
he combined i believe no no it was uh it
was
uh well no these are local
uh spots right right well because you
know grocery stores are kind of regional
right like you know certain regions i
guess tony well certain regions have
different grocery stores like
when you go to a when you go to a
different part of the country they're
called you know the grocery store like
downing
places
the two spots were wegner wegmans like
red nerves red oh and wegmans
like
mans and red nerds and then he combined
it and he called i'm at wagner's and
everyone's like the [ __ ] you are
where the [ __ ] is that we don't even
know where that is is that somewhere in
new jersey that's probably what they
were thinking maybe who knows maybe it's
a location
that he goes to wagner he's like i go to
wagner's all the time you know and it's
like
no you don't exist yeah it's not a thing
it's not a thing so everyone we have we
have texas paul coming up don't don't go
anywhere stick around
as soon as he gets his camera ready here
we but we we're going to come we're
going to go to a break and when we come
back and texas paul gets his camera
going we are going to talk
we're going to talk better o'rourke in
texas so stick around don't go anywhere
we'll be right back right after these
messages
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
i've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever i try it never
sticks so when babel made a mag edition
i knew i had to give it a try babble mag
edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon i was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that i'm struggling with i
chose babble mag edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now i can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new maga skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome
welcome welcome welcome welcome back to
the show
thanks for sticking around through the
break
[Music]
maybe it is a grocery store in new
jersey
hell i don't know maybe it is
maybe that's where he got the confusion
i i couldn't tell you i couldn't tell
you today is tuesday you know that
you know that today's tuesday and we on
on tuesdays we have a special guest that
joins us for tuesdays it just happens i
don't i don't know it just everyone
keeps staying i don't know what we
should call it whether we call it you
know today's taco tuesday officially and
we love taco tuesday here i love tacos
gabe loves tacos
our audience absolutely adores tacos
so it's taco tuesday but here on the
tony michaels podcast it has become
texas paul tuesday
so i'm not sure
how we can mine the name here
but i think he's got his camera working
so let's bring in texas paul texas paul
welcome to the tony michaels podcast
well you got it kind of working now look
look he's in front of the state capitol
there in texas yeah we've got a little
bit of a technical issue today we're
going to get i'm sorry about that it
happens it happens it happens i just you
just i just look really
really slender so that that's good
you should keep your camera like this
every single time so you're having some
technical difficulties over there paul
but tell me i've been wanting to ask you
about beto because beto is kicking ass
and taking names down in texas
but and we're going to talk about this
video where he called out the abbott
supporter
um
and um
and i believe i believe
that uh you have some commentary on the
but tell me
tell me a little bit about how betto's
doing and and if you have any more texas
news on the greg abbott site because i
know you said you wanted to mention
something there as well
you know folks always ask me why do you
think beto can win why do you think beto
can win and i'll tell you folks it's
because he's real
he's real
he's you know and you saw that the other
day when you had that jackass get
out of hand in in his rally you know
they show up and they they want to raise
hell and all kinds of [ __ ] like that
and it's just one problem after another
after another with these right-wing
[ __ ] but you know
they messed with the wrong irishman
there man he turned around and told that
guy
i loved it man i loved it he said you
know they
he had the reaction that a normal per
person would would have
you know it might be funny to you
[ __ ] but it's not funny to me
when you're talking about kids being
shot
you know it's it's
really just i loved it i absolutely
loved it and then on top of that you've
got
you know he he engages with
folks that are on the right you know he
doesn't just invite troublemakers in
people come in they hear him talk and
they hear his policies and
and he's winning people over left and
right you know and i love the fact that
abbott keeps sending people to beto and
veto keeps flipping them over to our
side
well i think you're right because i have
a video here i'm going to bring in gabe
sanchez gabe you had a little k you you
guys are having technical difficulties
we took the break my computer froze i
was like
and then
and then it had to restart so apologies
for that i think it's the deep state i
think it's a deep something it's coming
after me
paul's camera messing with you they
never mess with me they don't want it
i'm lagging a little bit i and tony i'm
a little bit upset with you having me
follow the great ben glebe man that guy
was hilarious but he made it up to me i
talked to him about it and uh he he sent
me a fresh jar of dolphin fetus oh
really okay
is it good
oh my god oh rich cracker they they
brine them down and they're really salty
and then they put them back in their
original uh you know placenta jelly
do you get do you get your dolphin
fishing is right out of them do you get
your dolphin venus at wagner's to put on
your charcuterie board is that where is
that what you do i don't know maybe
maybe maybe maybe you would get dolphin
fetus at uh at wegner's in new jersey to
put on your charcuterie board i don't
know i'm just saying some meat and
cheese right wouldn't dolphin fetus be
considered a meat i'm just i'm just
trying to figure this out here i don't
know i don't know all these fancy terms
i know it as a vegetable tray and a meat
and cheese tree that's what i know it's
what happens here in the midwest just
wanted to say great show yesterday ben
glee was hilarious he is ben is for you
ben is a lady did you did you end up
catching his special
um it's great
and you can go watch both of them um the
first one and we'll put them in the
links from yesterday's show so if you
want to find those just go to
yesterday's show the title was 14 oh
yeah 14 fbi agents
and the um
the number of the show i think is 205
can you believe that gabe we're at like
200 200
over 200 episodes crazy episodes that's
crazy crazy but texas paul you are right
um when when ben
gleeve that is one of my favorite
[ __ ] videos one of my favorite gabe
can you pull up the beto um
yeah the link for the better video
because i want to show that but but the
ben glebe charlie kirk video where he
just absolutely dunks him on the dolphin
fetus thing and then yesterday um i
don't know if if if you didn't watch you
got to go back and watch the episode
because he explains like how he set that
up what his goal was what his name was
how he's going to dunk charlie on dunk
on charlie kirk and then how he dunked
on him when charlie was mad at him so go
check out yesterday's episode you're
right picks texas paul yeah that that
interview with with ben is spot on and
maybe what we'll do
for the best of this weekend
is i'll put that interview with ben
glebe in the best of this weekend
because it wasn't hell of an interview
it's it's it's a it's a great it's a
great site to see but you know this
video of
of uh
of bet o'rourke going after
this abbott supporter um
is just as good or better don't you
think texas paul
absolutely absolutely that was just
people are loving that they are eating
that up
like crazy and by the way my pita people
back away from the keyboard that was a
raisin with some jelly that was nice
so
my pita people my animal lovers my
dolphin lovers can you all just
back away from the texas texas paws
texas paul
pissed off the
the dolphin protectors no i think we
should protect things like dolphins um
you know
and and really honestly uh i would
imagine that pro-life these forced
birthers probably would want even if it
the dolphin's life was on the line would
probably want to force a ten-year-old
dolphin um and make it cross-state lines
to save it's i'm just saying just saying
a young a young teenage a young a young
kid who who became a dolphin who became
pregnant probably across state lines to
save its life
because that um priceless
okay we'll see here's the here's the uh
better video and i want to fast forward
to this moment um because it's right
yeah it's right before here so what
betta was talking about is the evaldi
shooting and he's describing
um in very much detail
about how these children and these
teachers were ripped apart by these
weapons of war and how easy it was
for this
kid an 18 year old kid to receive these
weapons and get these weapons without
even really paying for him i mean he
used a credit card so he didn't even
really buy these weapons he just used a
piece of plastic to put him on loan
until he went and murdered these
children um but beto is describing here
how these children ripped apart and what
these weapons are actually used for
what they're what they're actually used
for in
the real world not not [ __ ] manga 2a
bro
uh alternate reality that they have
where you got to take a weapon to go
order a subway sandwich you know rather
you put your dolphin fetus on your
subways damage or not that might be a
different story but here is beto
describing what is happening down at
evaldi and there's there's an abbott
supporter in the room and i guess texas
paul they do this at a lot of these
community events that that betto does
because he doesn't do big rallies he
does these community events but the
rooms are packed the rooms are packed
and there's overflow from these events
because he's getting so popular and i'm
going to show a few more of those videos
but i guess these ambit supporters show
up at these events um and they kind of
heckle him and this guy thought it was a
good idea to laugh
while beto is describing little bitty
children being picked apart by an
assault weapon let's watch
hundreds of rounds of ammunition and
take that weapon that was originally
designed for use on the battlefields in
vietnam to penetrate an enemy soldier's
helmet at 500 feet and knock him down
dead
up against kids at five feet it may be
funny to you [ __ ] but it's not
funny to me okay
[Applause]
now what a what a moment in a campaign
and to use the word [ __ ] because
i think the tide is turning here in
texas ball because a lot of people you
know they're like oh tony cuss is too
much and they cuss over there on the
minus touch network and blah blah blah
blah blah yakity smackdown [ __ ] that
[ __ ] listen our democracy at stake our
way alive said steak and there's
children's lives at stake here and just
like beto said you may think it's funny
[ __ ] but it's not funny to me
it's not funny to me this idea that that
oh we're gonna [ __ ] ban book fairs
and take math out of schools and all
kinds of crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] be
absolutely obsessed with other people's
genitalia and bathrooms that you don't
need to be obsessed with all kinds of
crazy ass [ __ ] that these people just
think is [ __ ] funny they think it's
[ __ ] funny to run rough shot over our
democracy and i'm with bet o'rourke here
you may think it's money funny
[ __ ]
but it's not funny to me and i think
it's a serious thing now what we watched
though
is the media kind of have a heyday with
this because he said the word
[ __ ] did you notice that in
texas because the national thing the
national media like npr's like oh this
is gonna turn off voters to say the word
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] if you watch that room
erupt they're ready they're ready to
vote for someone to call this [ __ ] out
to call this fascism out what do you see
down there in texas
on the ground as you're there
everybody loved it
everybody loved it
i mean nobody had a problem with him
using the word [ __ ] it was
appropriate for what just happened
you know
left or right when you're talking about
those poor beautiful little babies that
were down in uvalde
being shot from feet away
with an ar-15
and
just
you know
i don't want to get too gross about it
but
if you've never seen what
those rounds do
it's not like shooting somebody with a
nine millimeter where you see on the
movie in the movies where there's a
little bitty bullet hole and then now
those bullets
when they penetrate
they massively create a shock wave
within the body that just
jellifies
the exit wounds are this big
now i want you to imagine a child
that's a fraction my size
with exit wounds that big
i mean
i just i don't i don't have words for
anybody that could laugh about that
and everybody knows this is not
something people didn't know about here
in texas everybody in texas knows about
this and that
[ __ ]
showed up to to make a stupid point
about guns
and ended up making a freaking buffoon
of himself and that's the way everybody
down here in texas feels about it
i think you're right and there's more
proof here's another video um from one
of these community events that betto
does um as you can see the gentleman
here is an elderly gentleman and listen
to what he says about how he's voted and
why he's going to
change his vote and change his vote to
federalism i'm definitely a reagan
republican reagan george h w bush and
dwight d eisenhower are
my republican heroes it's a privilege to
have somebody like peter o'rourke come
and talk to us
we've never had a governor here
32 years
and i was impressed with the gentleman
one
he's a very intelligent logical
interesting young man and it's nice to
have somebody like that run for the
governor of the state of texas and i do
appreciate his visit here more than i
can tell you it was equally important
that we had so many people here today so
i wish him the best
and i think he will probably get a lot
of good vote a lot of votes here in
sabine county
well and he actually um beto showed up
in a county where
and i'm not sure if it's this county or
another county where
donald trump won 85 percent of the vote
and it was absolutely packed um i
believe this is good signs now
i also believe that this is an effect
that we have not seen in an election yet
and it's the january 6 effect right we
have not watched we have not witnessed a
national election since donald trump and
his allies have tried to overthrow our
government in the name of the republican
party
i believe i believe that there is a a
large swath of people out there
that absolutely are going to change
their vote in this election to make
their voices heard about january 6 who
voted for trump twice
who voted for trump twice they're gonna
make their voices heard in this election
in this midterm that hey we are not okay
with this we are not on the side of the
coup this gentleman seems to change his
mind just just in the fact that bet
o'rourke is logical and he's a fine
young gentleman and it doesn't seem
texas paul that the word [ __ ]
turned this gentleman off on beto
o'rourke
no and i'll be honest with you you've
got to really
it's more than just january 6th
overturning roe
was something that
80 percent of the country didn't want to
happen
and er you know the vast majority of
republicans that could
so they could sleep at night told
themselves ah they're never really going
to do it
they're never really going to do it well
they did it
and that really woke a lot of people up
and what it did was it opened their ears
to people like you and me
and beto and people that are out here
talking and we are converting people
with every show with every video with
every town hall you know i'm i'm going
to speak just to some folks here um
i've got i've got speaking engagements
for the next
several weekends in a row and and it's
just
people are showing up that are normally
right-wing voters
and they're listening
and they're finding out that wow these
[ __ ] aren't crazy
they're talking about saving social
security uh
yeah they actually put their money where
their mouth is they just passed a bill
that capped my medicare out-of-pocket
expenses on my on my drugs at two
thousand dollars for the year
they they're really doing things for me
not just [ __ ] running their mouth
culture war games they're working for me
and and it's paying off
you know give yourself a pat on the back
give yourself some credit you and gabe
are converting people with your show
you know betto's converting people by
getting out there that's why he's done
so many town halls in the places he's
done them he's gone into the heart of
red texas i am telling you this is the
kind of
place where that where that
[ __ ] engagement was
is the kind of place
that you don't drive around with a
better sticker on your car
because there's a sorry piece of [ __ ]
that'll slash your tires or break your
window or you know what i mean they're
they're just
he's going into the heart of the beast
and he's talking
he's telling them put your money where
your mouth is look what we're doing look
what they're doing
i couldn't agree with you you more
on the fact that this is happening i
actually found um the video from the
packed room where beto spoke
um where donald trump won 85 of the vote
this is in decatur well that's how we
would say it here in missouri we'd say
decatur is that why is that how you
saying decatur okay
i figured down in texas it'd be about
the same not the same kind of talk
you know some some may pronounce it
different but in the stick
we may pronounce a town named buda buta
but that one's decatur decatur a cater
decatur okay well let's listen to beto
speaking in decatur texas where donald
trump won almost 85 percent of the vote
the pack room that democratic
gubernatorial candidate beto o'rourke
spoken thursday wasn't in dallas
it was decatur an accounting former
president donald trump won nearly 85
percent of the vote in this was one of
several stops in north texas
made the case that moving school funding
to private schools could actually hurt
the public system especially he says in
smaller communities o'rourke also
touched on improving the energy grid
why more than 11 weeks since those kids
and teachers were shot and killed in
that classroom has he not called a
special session
o'rourke was speaking to voters last
night at a town hall in mineral wells 50
miles west of fort worth the crowd
responded by giving o'rourke a standing
ovation these are the cities that greg
abbott's sleeping on um he's not showing
up he's not fighting for these folks
he's not earning the vote show him
gaining ground on governor rabbit who
just agreed to debate a work in
september
so there you go there's the video um of
beto running around the state um just
doing circles around greg abbott now i
believe it's his community talk texas
paul because he's saying things like
community he's talking about texas and i
believe that's one reason why john
fetterman is kicking ass in pennsylvania
why warnock is kicking ass in georgia
why tim ryan is slaughtering jd vance in
ohio is because democrats care about the
community they care about the state and
they care about the humans that make up
that community that is most important
and at the forefront of their campaigns
and the more they use this community
talk the better off they are but here's
here's the question
that i that i have
do you actually think that o'rourke is
going to win texas
oh absolutely
absolutely that's that's that's not just
i hope he wins i know he's going to win
because
you have to feel it here on the ground
this is a sea change
in this state
the
there are
you know you used to see
just everywhere
everywhere there would have been abbot
signs by now
i mean just carpeting
everything and it's not happening it's
just not happening people are sick and
tired they're looking around
you know
we're the energy capital capital of the
world or in tech well the energy capital
of the country anyways
hell the world really be honest when you
look at all everything we do here in
texas with oil and natural gas
it's embarrassing
that the latest class
of tankers
be serviced here
because the port of galveston the the
energy transfer
uh the oil transfer stations that are
that are out there
you know when if you take a cruise you
go buy them on the cruise ship you'll
see tankers anchored out all around them
can't service the latest class of
tankers
we can't you know the evergreen the ship
that got stuck in the suez canal
we can't unload that ship here in
galveston
they can't get that ship up to our dock
it it it's embarrassing that 25 years
ago
when republicans took control of this
state
that
we had you know a quarter century we
were cutting edge
i mean in medicine our electric grid
our roads
our ports everything galveston was
cutting edge a quarter century ago
but republicans came in and did nothing
but culture was
they do nothing when it comes to doing
the job and that's why we're reaching so
many people because
you know we're not being quiet about it
we used to be quiet about it and just do
our job that's what democrats did
they just did their job and they would
blackmail us with bills in congress
where we would be standing up for the
people and they would you know have to
get some goodies for some rich guy
for
for republicans to come over and vote
for something that was good for the
american people well we're getting loud
and proud about it now
you know we're telling people hey
[ __ ] it may be funny to you but
it's not funny to me
you know and it's really that fight
combined with
people are just sick
of republicans and they're [ __ ]
culture wars they're sick
of not
you know them not doing their jobs they
don't want marjorie taylor green they
don't want lauren bobert
you know you've got this one small
segment of a small fraction of the
society that wants to own the libs and
to them
you know government's a video game to
most people it's not it's real life
and people know it
and and we're walking the walk not just
talking the talk
well i think you're right when you say
people think it's a government video
game because gabe we we always say we're
at the intersection of wrestlemania in
real life that's kind of how you know i
like the government's a video game i
kind of like the the analogy there
because they they do and we continue to
see this we continue to see this and
it's not just in texas it's everywhere
um and and we're going to actually see
how this plays out in wyoming where liz
cheney like you said texas paul she
decided to do her job on on the coup
attempt she decided to be a member of
congress that was actually going to get
to the bottom of this she's done the
hard work and will wyoming reward her
for that work for actually doing
government or will they slam dunker we
will see we shall see today um but i
think
i think you're right that betto's gonna
win i think the polls are wrong i think
some of the some of the the narrative is
wrong in the media i think they get it
completely
wrong what do you think gabe you think
the media is getting some of these races
wrong where they're they're really off
to you and it it's not it's not
computing the way it should
yeah i i think they are i think uh
i can tell you for a fact i've never
been polled before uh for any sort of
election or even a concern consumer
survey so i don't know who who exactly
is being pulled
right um
but i think polls are something to be
skeptical they might be some sort of
baseline or metric to give you an idea
but they're not going to be the actual
end result right um
despite how
uh
future scene
um someone like nate silver might appear
to be or claims to be right but at the
end of the day like i think i think the
polls of late have been off right we've
seen it
in in the most recent mid uh the
primaries that have come up
um
and i think that's also true here and i
think you know
even if we look at states like uh uh
georgia or florida or texas like these
are areas that are
heavily gerrymandered and redistrict so
that it actually benefits the republican
party where a small number of people
have a large number of vote which is
again the republican
strategy right it is a small group of
people who want to uh decide the
the
rights and and access to a large
majority so i think in states like texas
where texas paul is right now like you
have a lot of people it's either blue or
it's purple but i really do believe it's
pool it is blue and so i think we're
gonna see that and right now this
outrage this strategic outrage that
people have had they are fed up right
they're seeing children slaughtered
they're seeing rights being taken away
from women they're seeing
uh just just the state of texas itself
under the rule of abbott be be destroyed
from what it should be right you're
talking texas paul talking about how
there was so much built
with with uh the oil and gas industry
and now they're they're not able to keep
up in certain ways and so i think
you know
we're coming to that that critical ju
that point in in the fork in the road
where people are saying do we continue
this way
and really let it be [ __ ] up or do we
turn the course and decide to fix
things before it's too late and so i
think the polls are wrong i think i
don't again i don't know who they're
polling
but i think the polls are wrong
um so much that you're seeing a district
that's 85 percent pro trump during the
20 uh the the last election
and you're finding out these people are
switching platforms because they're
saying that the guy didn't do anything
for me and the party's not doing
anything for me they're not caring about
me they're not empathetic they don't
care about people they would rather say
i'll put the money in my pocket and you
guys can go [ __ ] yourselves that voted
for me and so now i think these people
like even in that room there were people
that had maga gear on right they were
willing to listen to beto and what he
had to say so
i mean i think
i think the polls are wrong at the end
of the day like i think they might give
you an idea like i'm just getting a
pulse of whether people are alive or not
but i think really
what they're what they're indicating of
how they're voting is is off
well and i i think i think that's right
because um you know some of these polls
are you know a broken clock is ranked
twice a day you know but but so i think
some of these polls are going to be
accurate um and but a lot of them are
not and the reason why is because it's
really antiquated and and the other
reason why i think texas paul that these
polls [ __ ] suck to be quite honest
with you is because they are made for a
group of people uh the group of people
that these polls are made for is the
media the media is is what wants to
drive these polls and i'm not saying
that polling isn't important i
absolutely think polling is important
and it should be important to give us
those baselines like gabe is talking
about for the mood of the country in
each election at that for all sorts of
different issues maybe it's a candidate
maybe it's a certain issue or maybe it's
a bill maybe it's a policy there's all
kinds of things that polling is so
important but i think the way we do
polls is totally antiquated um it's
totally passed i mean we're doing
they're doing polls still on technology
that was 15 20 years ago like why in the
[ __ ] are they still doing that why why
haven't they caught up to speed i mean
jesus christ we consume so much
information these days people are more
educated now on what is happening in the
country just on the information that
they consume than they ever have been
whether it's real information or
misinformation is part of the problem
but texas paul this brings me to my
point the media the media are the ones
who rely on these polls because it sets
their narrative and i believe the media
is way off the mark on all these races
they're way off the mark
on this bull sizing [ __ ] um it is
becoming more and more apparent that
they're way off because the people are
leaving these media outlets in droves
watching them they're coming watching
shows like ours and and eclipse like
yours on the midas touch network because
they know that the media is just
just a bunch of [ __ ] hot air
you and you hit it on the head that the
old technology is a problem because
we're educating people we're
putting facts out let me give you an
example
um
right now
abbott is running
a push saying that
he tried to expand medicaid if you can
believe it
a big misconception about texas is we're
a rich state we are not a rich state
we're a resource rich state
but
you know elon musk doesn't live here he
claims to live here because it's a tax
dodge for him so he skews the figures
of
you know how wealthy your
the the median income you know what the
median income is and how wealthy we
actually are here so a lot of people
rely on medicare here we're a much
poorer state than you would you would
think a lot of people are moving here
because it's cheap to live here because
we are a poor state
we need medicaid expansion desperately
abbott sends an application in to dc
for medicaid expansion that they know
will purposely fail
they left out say you're you're a
pregnant
mom okay you're pregnant
you have a car wreck
your placenta tears that's a
life-threatening injury it happens a lot
with pregnant women that have car wrecks
especially front-end collisions because
of the force moving forward tears of
placenta and you're bleeding internally
in the state of texas they can't save
you
and when they send in the medicaid
when they send in the medicaid
application they intentionally left
dnc's and dnes out of
what they will do as far as emergency
care
so
medicaid has basic standards
if you want the money you have to have
basic standards of health care
they knew they weren't going to mean it
so they're running around telling
everybody oh just because
biden wanted abortion
he won't approve our medicaid expansion
because we won't do abortions well no
it's because if a mom
gets injured and needs you know or has
an ectopic pregnancy and needs emergency
care
medicaid will cover that but not here in
the state of texas because it's illegal
so they knew the application would fail
people are smarter now because of you
and me
arming them with this information so
abbott's running around trying to tell
people well i tried to explain medicaid
and they wouldn't do it because all they
wanted was abortion people are saying
[ __ ]
we know what you pulled we know what you
pulled
and
it's it's all the difference in the
world
you know these social media battles that
play out on facebook aren't one-sided
because of russia disinformation because
you and i and gabe and everybody else at
midas we're arming these people with
information and they're going out there
and they're not taking [ __ ] off people
well i think you're right and i think
everyone
needs to start considering turning off
some of these networks
walking away when they're starting to
both sides things and coming to the
midas touch network uh texas poll i know
you put out more
midas touch network publishes a lot of
texas paul videos but texas paul
publishes a lot of videos on his own so
go follow texas paul on twitter on
instagram and on the tiki tax texas paul
where can they go to follow you
uh it's paul tx890 on instagram on
uh
tiktok on twitter
just do a search for texas paul
schroeder just you'll find me on just
about every social media out there well
go follow texas paul and go follow the
minus touch network because you want to
stay up to speed on all these breaking
news topics as they post clips over
there um texas paul thanks for joining
us on tuesday we much appreciate it
we're
it just stretched me at the last minute
i don't we'll get we'll get it figured
out for next yeah next week you'll be
super you'll be stretched this way yeah
we'll get you this we'll get you this
way next week so all right thanks paul
for joining us we appreciate it and
we'll see you soon my friend i've got an
idea for you uh off air that i wanna
that i wanna bring up to you okay so
don't so don't uh don't be ignoring my
messages when i no i'm always here for
you brother i i know you you're you're
quick to respond you fought you respond
faster than gay beer so uh you know it's
it's you guys are on the same time zone
that's oh i'm on that post is that what
you're doing you know you wouldn't
understand
yeah no it's it's it's got a different
we got the central time zone mindset in
texas paul thanks for joining us can i
ask you one short question sure
you asked me about texas what is where
you're at looking like i mean i know
missouri well i mean missouri i'll tell
you real quick before we go to a
commercial break uh missouri just has a
recreational marijuana um referendum go
on the ballot it's a referendum here in
missouri and i believe there's going to
be a lot of people go to the polls to
vote for that referendum and i believe
that if bush valentine the democrat who
won
the the democratic primary i believe as
she leans into it even being a bush heir
bush beer heir if she leans into that
recreational marijuana uh referendum she
definitely will beat the attorney
general who who is against marijuana um
i believe that there's a good chance
that there is a there's a shadow ballot
there where a democrat could even win
could even win the senate seat in
missouri and it has to do with roe but
it also has to do with
you know just simple good policy and
people wanting people in charge that are
going to do good policy and not worry
about owning the libs so i think you're
right i think you're right i think it
could happen all around the country not
just in texas texas paul thank you for
joining us we'll see you soon my friend
next tuesday next tuesday remember have
your camera going up and down
we'll see you soon my friend everyone
stick around we will be right back right
after this break
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the tony
michaels podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day recurring
and it means you'll get these trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[Music]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the
show sticking through the break texas
paul everybody
called tuesday
we know it's texas fall tuesday and it's
taco tuesday gabe sanchez taco
tuesday
are you gonna are you gonna have tacos
today
probably i haven't decided what i want
the last two nights i we uh we made a
like a
a chicken tortilla soup
uh um so last night we had leftovers so
who knows maybe we'll have uh
tacos tonight or might try to like
switch it up just for tonight i don't
know we will see the day is still very
young at least on the west coast
what time is it there six in the morning
or is it always yeah it is it crashes
in the morning out there always
when i actually when i when i always
when you next time
in the morning i'm like hey man we need
art for the day
he's he's he hadn't even wiped the
boogers out of his eyes
i am still asleep and i'm like thumbs up
you know
right and i i know that's what's
happening he didn't no honestly i'm
trying to i tried to get as much sleep
as i can because i i don't go to bed
early i go to bed late now i probably
should switch that like
you know the healthy thing would be to
go to bed earlier
but i don't know
i like staying up late and then you know
getting that's why the show's at noon
new year's easter yeah but here
otherwise i'd have to show it at 8
o'clock in the morning you can go to bed
late and you can wake up late and still
do the show
i can go to bed late and then i have to
wake up you know my because my the show
starts for me at 9 00 am but even starts
earlier than that when i'm making the
thumbnail for this guy he's working hard
over there i promise folks from early in
the morning until late at night he's
always working hard um so don't forget
you see the new support link here and it
helps support the show and all the work
that gabe does here uh support dot
tonymichaelspod.com
also the qr code is there don't forget
to go support the show show gave some
support
because he does have to get up early in
the morning so you want to make sure you
fund his early morning his early morning
artwork because that's where that's
where the the thumbnail comes from every
single day is
i definitely don't do those for sure 100
well i've tried a couple times and they
suck they're old it's okay you know we
try my best know what our strengths are
you know what the hell is that supposed
to mean i'm just saying like we know
right we know what lane we are in you
know right so what lane am i in i know i
don't know you're just like the loud
mouthing no shit's giving midwestern i
got you read backwards yelling
i i yell into the microphone no [ __ ]
given
you just make the art yeah
but yeah sure well right i know but look
at the beautiful art look at the
beautiful art that we have on the screen
here this is all yeah this is this is
quite this is uh i'm not gonna say this
is my masterpiece but it's it's
something we've come a long way
for the tony michaels podcast in the
last year it's come a long way i mean
let let's let's think about this we're
on episode what two two 206 206.
i came on i joined at episode 50. holy
[ __ ] well that was what he was that's
when we interviewed him once a week
right yeah that was we did once a week
interviewed the midas uh brothers we had
that yeah it was brent jordy
remember we did the game and then you do
the game show again yeah we need who
liked the game
yeah who who who in the comments who
remembers the game show yeah we should
we should do the game show you know we
should do we should just say [ __ ] it and
we should do the games live too
yeah we should you just have a game
can you bring people on do the game i
think when we have our new uh setup
we're we're looking at right now yeah
and we can easily you know it might be a
little maybe the question up on the
screen at the same time right have some
sound effects right right yeah well you
know
we got to get more technically advanced
maybe and that'll that'll help because
things are coming here at the tony
michael's podcast things are coming
changes and they're good changes
everyone keeps saying we need to go to
three hours which oh that's a heavy lift
we definitely need three hours to talk
about all the [ __ ] we need to talk about
right yeah but but as far as going to
three hours boy it's a heavy lift for us
um over here with the show just because
we are doing so much behind the scenes
to try to to try to level up
um and and we're we're getting closer
and closer to leveling up and a lot of
people are going to level up when we
level up i think i think yeah i think i
think you know a rising tide lifts all
boats
absolutely you know and it's not again
we talk about the elections being
important and i believe this election
that we have in front of us is the most
important and as soon as those votes are
counted as soon as we put that that vote
in the books the next election will be
the most important vote for our
democracy and we have to stay
pro-democracy we cannot relent we cannot
let down we have to lean into it and
that is the most important part here is
we cannot put up with anyone who is not
going to lean into democracy and i think
that's i think that's showing through
like we talked with texas paul that's
showing through in texas ohio
pennsylvania georgia i think i think
stacey abrams has a damn good chance i
don't did you see in florida um
not not to give to polls too much credit
here but also but all of a sudden val
dimmings yeah
for what it's worth again you can't
believe every poll so you have to lean
into this thing you can't relent but the
poll is showing that val dimmings is
moving um
you know and that may be where we where
we're at with polls because we talked
about it being antiquated because i
think how they do polls is totally
antiquated to call someone on the phone
that doesn't make any sense at all what
the [ __ ] i mean like here have you ever
been called on the phone well i have
been called for a poll before someone
was it for a consumer related poll or
was it for actually i've i've had i've
had a voter poll and i've had a consumer
poll before they were they both of them
were in different cycles
um
they had different questions they had
different aims but who [ __ ] calls
someone on a on a phone or a poll yeah
who does that i mean i believe that
there's also who i mean there's a lot of
questions there too it's like you know
it what is the number you know like are
people do people still have landlines
that's a whole nother thing too oh right
well if you're getting a phone call
you're gonna answer that on your cell
phone
you'll also might be flagged like
potential spams you're like no i don't
want to answer that but a lot of people
you know um with cell phones they have a
cell phone that they've had for 15 20
years and they move from one part of the
country to the other part and it's a
completely different number so you can't
trust you can't trust the number anymore
so i feel like now again i don't know
what the answer is i don't know if
there's some sort of snap great thing
that we can come up with
with the technology but i know
technology is so advanced today to make
sure to verify who someone is verify
that they're an actual voter or not a
voter
there's so much technology that could be
used to make sure that these polls are
more accurate and we the people
out here in the government because we
are the government maybe we could
actually have technology
that would be not be so goddamn
antiquated and these polls would be a
lot more reliable but again gabe i think
it goes back to who is actually relying
on these polls who wants these polls who
wants to push these polls it's the
[ __ ] media and i'm not saying media
is is a bad thing i don't want to to
make people think that i'm against the
media i'm actually for good media yeah
yeah and that is responsible right yeah
and we have in the mainstream media
right now they have a profit motive and
their profit motive is to try to push
this both sides thing and that is not
what we're going to do here we are not
going to do the bull side [ __ ] because
it's all [ __ ] we are not going to
we're not going to say that the democrat
party is the same same as the republican
party because they clearly are not joe
biden is going to sign a bill today
that only democrats passed only
democrats got done and actually
republicans did their damnedest to make
sure that this thing didn't pass so that
the american people didn't receive the
benefits in the inflation reduction act
which most of it is health care cost
that it's gonna because health care
costs
a lot of american especially elder
americans are up against a lot of health
care costs and that's where a lot of
their inflation costs are coming from is
health care and this bill at this bill
helps that with not just the medicaid
medicaid medicare payments but also the
prescription drugs which is a huge cost
for americans
and the republicans did their damnedest
not to have this just like they did
their damnedest to trying to not to try
to loan the libs on the pack act right
it just it's on and on it goes i mean
he's had a let's just call it what it is
like he's had an a very very good two
weeks of accomplishing
certain
aspects of legislation that he has
promised or is working with and
republicans have
you know
if not every single time said
nope not gonna do that not gonna help
out the american people
um
it's just one of those
well it's it's the unfortunate truth
right like you know they're they're busy
trying to figure out their own thing
because they're like do we stay with
trump do we not stay with trump are we
willing to go down and be
you know mentioned
well we're gonna have plenty of these
stores we're gonna have plenty of these
stories today um especially in the [ __ ]
list roundup here because there's
several primaries that are going on and
we're already almost at the bottom of
the second hour here so we have to get
to the [ __ ] list so let's surf the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends
let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome back to the show welcome
to the shitless roundup where we round
up all the tweety treats and trendy
trends
there's a lot of [ __ ] going on today a
lot of [ __ ] to round up gabe a lot of
[ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] a lot of the last
couple weeks has been a lot of [ __ ] oh
my scooping and
tossing
scooping
tossing it's a lot of that it's a lot of
that a lot of that well there's several
videos here um from some of your
favorites uh let's start with the
herschel walker here oh he thinks he
thinks we should bring down the economy
he thinks we should bring down the
economy he's saying the quiet part out
loud oh boy he he's a
he doesn't even know what economy is
that's the problem hold on hold on hold
on this is from the truth
gazette
does this sound that the fraud gazette
like
these people literally they just they
just
you they say one thing and they mean the
opposite
now i'm like no i'm curious to learn
about this truth gazette okay we'll look
that up while i play because this is not
this this this uh this video of stupid
is not very long because of this
herschel walker people on the left they
have nothing to run on
right now they can't stand behind the
policies that they're uh they've voted
for
and my message is i want to bring this
uh the economy down he wants to bring
the economy down
he wants to bring the economy down
what the [ __ ] does that mean i have
no idea is today opposite day is he
trying to say like he wants to bring it
up
well i think he means like he wants to
bring prices down but he thinks economy
is pro i don't know
it's very unclear what this [ __ ]
bonehead yeah
it's very i don't think he knows half
the time what the hell he's talking
about um there is a a a video of another
dum-dum here we go uh more boneheads um
she started a new
um fart squad i'm not [ __ ] you
fart squad
this is real this is real she says it
out loud fart
squad
i mean i'm all for farts farts are
[ __ ] yeah you know flashlights it's
great yeah for sure i mean it's funny it
makes you laugh and it doesn't matter
where it is
even when you smell it it's still kind
of funny but
she is starting a fart squad
in the congress listen
they want those bills to pass by
unanimous consent so
myself and other members of the house
freedom caucus we have a floor action
response team f.a.r.t i'm a mother of
four boys i can appreciate that i do
love that we have the coc confetti of
color i do love the yes little names
there so we have the floor action
response team and we monitor the house
floor
or the suspension bills and we are there
to object to the unanimous consent of
its passing so we force members of
congress to vote and we have people get
pissed at us every single week because
they have to be in the house chambers
voting instead of being wined and dined
by lobbyists and i mean call me crazy
but i think legislators should be
legislating while they're in dc not
being influenced and manipulated and
bought by lobbyists so here's what she's
saying and i don't know if people know
this and patriot takes brought this out
um and patriot takes it says lauren
brobert describes how her fart team i
called it the fart squad because i
really think it should be called the
fart squad and and the acronym is floor
action response team monitors bills on
the floor now democrats do this too i
just don't think they call it the fart
team yeah or the fart squad
so what happens is is when you bring a
bill to a floor the floor you can ask
for unanimous consent right and
basically meaning that if no one objects
to unanimous consent then the whatever
measure they're voting on whatever it is
it doesn't matter if they're voting to
adjourn if they're voting to open the
meeting if they're voting for recess
whatever the hell they're voting on on
the floor
if they ask for unanimous consent and no
one objects to that unanimous consent
that is currently on the floor
then the vote passes it passes with
unanimous consent now
what she's saying is they have the fart
team
which
i don't know if they're they're actually
farting on the congress floor i would
imagine these people well i mean they're
certainly [ __ ] that's right that's
right they are [ __ ] on them
on our democracy but here's the thing
here's here's what they do so they go on
the house floor to make sure when when
the body the the congress the house
calls unanimous consent for a vote
they object and it's everything
absolutely it doesn't matter what it is
and what it does is it pisses off the
other people of congress where there is
unanimous consent where they would vote
on something that has
unanimous consent there what they're
trying to do is just get everyone on the
record and it pisses republicans off too
this isn't just and that's what she's
saying here this isn't just to get it
libs right this isn't just to own limbs
because what republicans have to do is
then they have to go down to the floor
or they have to do a proxy vote
a congress a congress person can do a
proxy vote on the house floor a senator
cannot vote proxy on the senate floor
they can on the house floor so what
happens is is now all these
[ __ ] that they want to get on
the record that they're voting for this
thing they've got to walk to the house
floor to make this vote that is why when
you watch a lot of these committee many
meetings gabe
like it looks like the deus of congress
people is empty and the reason why is
because they're all going to vote
yeah but they're all voting on something
because
maybe they the fart team has farted on
the they've [ __ ] like you said on the on
the for congress and now they have to go
[ __ ] they've called the vote because
in in in in
in the halls of congress there's there's
an announcement that goes out that
there's going to be a floor vote then
they have to go to the floor to vote so
this this idea what she's talking about
here
is exactly to [ __ ] on everyone in
congress not just republicans it pisses
off our democrats it pisses off
republicans too right because they're
making it's making their job to where if
they want unanimous consent and they're
in a in a very important committee
hearing they don't is really boneheaded
she's a bonehead but you know they're
all boneheads even rudy giuliani
giuliani girl you in danger rudy
giuliani is completely [ __ ] here this
is a report
from scott mcfarland a friend of the
show and we love we love to follow
scat's twitter account here but this is
him reporting on cbs this morning about
rudy
rudy kaluti grandpa farty mcarty rudy
giuliani let's watch movement in
multiple investigations involving former
president trump and his associates there
is strong strong pushback from the
justice department about the release of
information regarding the mar-a-lago
surge investigators say the move could
threaten its ongoing case but that isn't
the only investigation with new
developments this morning trump's former
lawyer rudy giuliani says he's the
target of a criminal probe in another
case a grand jury is looking into
efforts to influence and overturn the
2020 election results captain heritage
is following the mar-a-lago case for us
but we'll start with scott mcfarland on
what's going on with giuliani in georgia
scott good morning nate good morning
giuliani's attorney confirms to cbs news
the former new york mayor appears
tomorrow before that grand jury in
atlanta it's one of several
investigations that are accelerating
with some connection to the former
president or his close confidants
giuliani served as then president
trump's personal lawyer in the weeks
after the 2020 election making unfounded
claims of fraud and misconduct by
georgia election officials i don't have
to be a genius to figure out that those
votes are not legitimate votes giuliani
talked about the grand jury at his new
york city radio show monday they have
now told me that i'm the target i'm a
target of their atlanta investigation it
means that the investigation has
gathered enough evidence to alert the
person that they may face an indictment
and that's serious former president
trump has been under scrutiny for his
own efforts to challenge the georgia
election results including his call to
secretary of state brad raffensberger
days before january 6. trump has denied
all wrongdoing look brad i got to get
i have to find
12 000 votes another trump ally south
carolina republican senator lindsey
graham asked a judge to block a subpoena
from the georgia grand jury amid
questions about his own phone call to
georgia election officials he argued he
was doing his due diligence before
voting to certify the election and
should be shielded from having to
testify
the judge disagreed there are many
things that they don't have to answer
but that's only for things that deal
with their legislative duties their
official duties it does it's not a get
out of jail free card
graham is expected to appeal in this
case but for now is set to appear before
that grand jury next tuesday the 23rd in
a separate case first reported by the
new york times trump organization chief
financial officer allen weisselberg is
expected to reach a plea deal with new
york prosecutors in a tax fraud case
there
uh oh
uh oh gabe sounds like uh the the
investigations are heating up you really
are getting getting heated here but you
know this goes back to that people
aren't held accountable for what they
what they what they want to be held
accountable for like lindsey graham says
i want to be held accountable for my my
duty as a senator to certify the vote
that's what he's saying his
accountability is for and that's what he
was doing his due diligence well if
that's the case mr graham lady g if
that's the case why can't you go down
and and tell them that why can't you go
if you all did nothing wrong right and
you're all innocent
and you're being persecuted so unfairly
and the truth
the truth that you say hi everyone
is that you didn't do anything wrong
then [ __ ]
just go testify go give your go give
your statement go talk you know right
right because if there's no evidence of
a crime and and we've watched we've
watched as the former
guy is freaking the [ __ ] out on fraud
social just absolutely freaking out on
fraud social he continues to do this
stuff
if there is no evidence of a crime what
the [ __ ] are you people so concerned
about if you really didn't do this the
fear they have gabe is to incriminate
themselves now
i actually you sent me a link it is it
is a piece of um i don't know this this
is this is crazy this is a apparently
you found this on the deep dark parts of
the web or something this is a an
unboxing of the speaking of evidence
yeah we're talking about evidence yeah
this is an unboxing of the evidence it
was pretty pretty crazy to see this
crazy ass [ __ ] unboxing the unboxing of
the evidence that was that was collected
at mar-a-lago now this apparently is an
fbi agent who is unboxing this um
this stuff here so let's let's listen
and let's watch the unboxing
of this um this fbi
um evidence that they collected at
mar-a-lago let's watch hi everyone it's
your favorite fbi agent
batch number
and today i'll be doing an unboxing
video of box a33 this is one of the
boxes we took from trump's mar-a-lago
home now let's unpack our first item
looks like we have some packaging here
you know some basic paper
um actually never mind these are
shredded documents here we have what
seems to be an industrial-sized bottle
of adderall now most of this seems to be
written in russian
and i don't speak russian so i don't
know what it means but i can say i'm
pretty sure this is illegal to have the
next item are photos of melania trump
with french president emmanuel macron
this comes with a letter from donald
trump to tony ornato dated on
valentine's day
oh wow um
this has a lot of swear words in there
all right this is a top secret folder
that has not written on it let's take a
look inside
oh
oh wait does that look like someone
spilled the ketchup
yep that is definitely ketchup and here
we have a dvd that's titled from russia
with love starring donald j trump and he
seems to be
soaked in some sort of yellow liquid
weird
oh god these are the p-tapes make sure
to give this video a like and smash that
subscribe button
[Music]
what was that about what was that what
was that that is crazy
that is crazy
come on
did you find that where did you find
this video
i just dude i found it on the internet
man that's and here's the thing it
sounds like it sounds like real it's
not real but also too like fbi agent
anonymously
anonymously giving an unboxing video
what's going on there you know this is
kind of that feels like somebody's
breaking the law but thank you whoever
that person is is a patriot you know
right well and that's only here's the
thing
that is only
one
box right one that's probably not even
all the contents so you're saying this
mate you're you're saying that this fbi
agent may be releasing more unboxing
videos
look look dude
if i were to put myself in their place
it's possible
but for the time being i would say
yeah this is the only one right now
right i guess it really depends like if
this fbi agent gets a ton of positive
feedback and they say
if this if this video if this video of
this fbi agent unboxing these videos
goes you know even just remotely a
little bit viral yeah yeah then this
guy's definitely going to release more
right then who knows maybe he comes back
and he says let's go through box a71 you
know let's figure out what these well
they're talking how many there was like
28 boxes so really yeah yeah they're
they're a ton of boxes and you know
there's
there's a there's a leather journal like
what's in that i don't know you know
what are the top secret documents
you think he has maybe there's fake
passports in these things i don't know i
mean donald trump i'm screaming about it
but i'll i'll share that video later on
you know today okay good after the show
you know just make sure that people are
aware
of what's going on maybe we'll put a
copy of it up on the uh the youtube
channel so don't forget to subscribe to
the tony michaels podcast youtube
channel check out the parody and satire
uh playlist that we have i'm sure that's
where this one will end up because we're
just i mean we don't know so we don't
want to make any fact checkers on
twitter completely look what i will say
is a certain fact checker seth uh
did not
understand tweets that were sent out
yesterday
and are you serious again
yeah yeah but this one was uh
blocked me so again again
i only saw it because somebody sent me a
screenshot it wasn't about me it was not
about me it was about someone else and
it was how he had interpreted
uh the the passports that were collected
you know i see which we know now is a
lie because well they took them but they
gave them right back because they
realized that they wrongly took them
yeah there was a there was a middleman
there who filtered it to say oh no we
don't actually which only proves it only
proves that they're lying sacks of [ __ ]
when they say oh they're taking
documents that have nothing to do with
something like yeah but if they are
they're clearly giving it back there's
evidence of the contrary and two of them
were expired so it's like you don't even
need those differences but then the
other time he's like you got to remember
that he also was in new york so he has a
passport right i flew to new york he has
a passport i don't understand what the
hell just in case
right but here's well you got to sk you
might have to skip the country somewhere
here's the thing i mean normal people do
that like look gabe if they can actually
search a criminal who used to be the
president they can search your house if
you're a criminal too the other thing
about it is if you were an average
person and you wanted to skate on
federal crimes and fly to russia you
wouldn't want them to take your passport
either yeah i mean this is only american
free free american type stuff speaking
of people who are terrified because i
believe that's what's happening here is
these trump supporters and trump himself
are absolutely terrified of the evidence
that they collected because there
apparently seems to be
even more sealed documents from the
court which would indicate that maybe
there's a search warrant that hasn't
been executed yet
uh on on i don't know maybe a casket in
a certain ditch off a whole one in
bedminster i don't know i don't know
exactly what that warrant is for i'm
just surmising here
but there are other people that seem
completely terrified laura ingram has
tuck tailed and run against trump said
we need to dump him but jim jordan on
her show last night was not ready to do
that he seems really close he looks like
he is going to [ __ ] start crying he
looks like he is he's his face there's a
glisten he looks like he's sweating i
have a big problem with this video once
we after we're done playing it we'll
talk about it but yeah okay well let's
play it it's not that long come on
nothing makes sense here we know this
was unprecedented unwarranted uh it was
just plain wrong and i think when you
couple it with what think about last
week in a five-day time period we had
the president's personal residence rated
we had the phone of a sitting member of
congress taken and we had 87 000 irs
agents unleashed on the american people
and then you think about oh this was so
sensitive we waited 18 months to get it
no one believes these folks but they see
their government being turned against us
we the people we the citizens and that's
the frightening part so when president
trump says turn down the heat for
goodness sake they should because
turning down the heat means following
the constitution that's the concern here
what a whiny little [ __ ] you know what
i i i said he can [ __ ] all the way off
oh yeah just [ __ ] all the way up dude
hundred percent this is 100 nonsense all
this is nonsense that he just said in
this video
also so like he goes in the last five
day period you know we've had uh we've
had the home of a former president rated
nope it was legally searched like you
can use rated sure we could talk rated
but in the end
it was yeah but even a raid is a [ __ ]
i mean even if you have the legal
president to do a raid it's still legal
right but then it was unwarranted um
there was a search warrant it was an
actual legal
warrant
the legal search
of donald trump's home and the last part
87 000 irs agents
just unleashed on the american people
let's just back up this is an absolute
back up and correct this [ __ ]
disinformation
87 000 irs agents
they plan to hire over a 10 year period
right also if you can hire 87 000 people
in five days holy [ __ ] why the [ __ ] are
we complaining that's 87 000 people that
now have jobs
right
exactly well here's all these gun-toting
irs agents that's the other [ __ ]
what that's the other [ __ ] thing
because gabe we've talked about this
several times most of these irs ages are
going to be sitting in [ __ ] cubicles
or remotely at their home answering
their [ __ ] phone you can't call the
irs you can't do it i don't know i no
i'm tears
when we get off the broadcast here open
up your phone try to call the [ __ ]
irs and see if you're going to get a
hold of them oh no no i know i know i
was just thinking like what happens
maybe maybe these people call in to the
irs and that irs now is some
crime-fighting agent with a gun you know
they come out and they start kicking
down doors and that's the irs that the
republicans think are actually going to
be employed have you ever have you ever
have you ever encountered an irs agent
that had a badge have you ever
encountered uh no no i've only seen him
on tv i was i was sitting i was and i i
believe this was years ago when i was a
teenager i was sitting in my uncle he he
owned a retail store and i was i was
helping him watch the retail store at
the time and i was sitting behind the
counter an irs agent walks in she
flashes her bed she's got a briefcase
she looks official and she's looking for
an address the problem is he was on the
south end of the actual street she was
looking for the address on the north end
and and she knew she would she was like
i really don't know where i'm at i'm not
sure
she's like i know this is south but this
is the address where's north
and it was a business that was known to
be in trouble in the town like they were
known to be in trouble and that but when
she pulled out that bad just but it
wasn't like she had a gun and she was
like everyone down everyone down you
know that's not that someone happened i
don't know i don't know
as we're talking about this and as i
mentioned this irs agent i'm now
thinking of ideas in my head
[Music]
there may be a video on the deep dark
web there might be a
a pocket protecting gun toting audit
checking
irs agent that comes to your door
and does your taxes but she looked
official she looked like a government
agent she had a she had a badge you know
like a little like a little wallet and
her id but she wasn't scary she was like
yeah i'm looking for this place here i'm
really confused where she didn't like
bust down the door with a swat team that
is not what happened she was just
looking for these people who probably
owed the government oh what's those
things called taxes i don't understand
what the [ __ ] why
we have an internal revenue service it's
our internal revenue service it is the
it is the revenue department of our
government they collect the money from
from just average citizens who owes
taxes rich people who owe a [ __ ] load of
taxes and they investigate people who
might be tax cheats donald trump um that
is the thing that is most important here
is that they investigate
crimes that are committed against our
revenue service this isn't this these
are white collar money crimes it's not
like
you know the irs agents are looking for
a bunch of [ __ ] drug dealers and
stuff that is not exactly what is
happening here and the idea the idea
that jim jordan thinks that last week
the federal government hired 87 000
people and all of a sudden this week
they have guns they have badges and
they're breaking down doors to kill
rhinos wait that's a different that's
another different guy that's a different
guy
they're they're going after average
americans it's [ __ ] absolutely
laughable and ridiculous and it's no
wonder it is no wonder the tide is
turning because this is the same guy
who act like joe biden had a gasoline
button on his desk and was and was
intentionally making gas more expensive
he was saying that [ __ ] jim jordan for
months was saying joe biden is making
your gas more expensive intentionally
when it was the opposite what he was
doing and now and then you know what
crazy he made it lower
and less money intentionally just using
it just using his logic holy push the
button that said price go up he pushed a
button that said price go down right
just using just using old jimbo's
logic there right he's a [ __ ]
bonehead he's an absolute bonehead and
really honestly i think jim jordan's in
trouble here just like others at fox
news are in trouble
because they're really
not just with their narrative but it
might be even uh liable because tucker
carlson's back
oh yeah i saw that he is back and
laughing last week he actually uh he was
not on his show because he was so
embarrassed for five days he's really
trying to change his diapers actually
they said he had a planned vacation and
i forget who it was but someone in the
right-wing media surmised it might have
been charlie kirk surmised that they
planned this raid
because tucker was on vacation i'm like
you but you people are such dumb
[ __ ] you are so dumb
i'm serious i think charlie kirk said
that [ __ ] look look it up see if you can
find it but here is iris tucker carlson
the the bow tie rube is back on his show
but listen to how he's preparing his
audience for trump committing crimes and
that it's going to come out into the
open that yeah he's a criminal watch
there's nothing to see here
that's the line and no doubt asa
hutchinson and mitch mcconnell and dan
crenshaw and the rest of them why why
does he pick these three first off i i
think the reason why he picks these
rhinos well but they're also anti i mean
they're they've clearly well the reason
is because they're within the republican
party right and he's trying to say hey
look i don't just attack democrats i go
after republicans too i make sure that
they're accountable and these are the
people that have either supported the
gen 6 committee and what they found have
supported the legal search
that was done on donald trump's home or
any of the other things that are
investigated within the republican party
these are the people that are like yeah
okay some dumb was something was done
illegal so you know yeah we support
that's fine you know marjorie taylor
green and lauren bober and all these
other [ __ ] idiots are dumb
and tucker carlson takes it personally
and he goes that's an attack on me and
so he goes i'll go after my own people
i don't you mean white dudes okay so
here's here's what here's the that's him
that's him i'm not racist i go after
white i go after white people i got the
white dudes too now here's here's what i
think these three
um
crusty white dudes have in common here
these three people are super excited and
he knows inside the republican beltway
as it were that these three people are
super excited if donald trump just takes
a hit and gets indicted and goes to
prison these three people will heavily
benefit from donald trump going away
in the form and fashion that is a that
is
that is
exactly what democrats and liz cheney
and others like adam kinzinger and the
republican party have been saying
is these three benefit from that
especially the one in the middle that's
why i think his picture is the biggest
here is because mitchell there's no
there's no republican more excited on
the hill right now than mitch mcconnell
look at that giddy turtle smile yeah
they probably took this picture right
after trump was raided like how do you
feel how do you feel
mr turtle and that was his that was his
look when when they when they asked him
but let's listen to what else tucker has
to say here we tell you the very same
thing when the biden justice department
or some other state law enforcement
agency under their influence finally
does what you know they're going to do
which is indict donald trump obviously
they're going to do that
so he's preparing his audience yeah and
and this is the thing
that i've been saying for a long time
we've been saying for a long time that
he is going to get indicted it is only a
matter of time
because it's not just about the crimes
before he was president while he's
present but he's still committing crimes
as we speak today and he's not protected
by being the president yeah and he's not
running he won't run it's not going to
happen i wish he would run but it's not
going to happen he's not going to do
that he's going to be indicted and and
tucker carlson is trying to prepare his
audience but he also tries to
go one step further gabe and prepare his
audience here for not just an indictment
and criminal charges but the actual
evidence coming out in the open because
donald trump's going to go to trial and
and when donald trump does go to triumph
or whatever he's indicted for this
evidence is gonna get out in the open
who knows how maybe they'll produce
surveillance video from mar-a-lago
apparently they've already subpoenaed
that we'll spend the next year talking
about how it shows trump mishandling
classified information
there you have it there you have it
tucker carlson is not dumb he knows
exactly what he's doing exactly the
questions that he's asking and how he's
brainwashing and deluding his audience
and what he's doing here is setting up
is setting up his audience of what he
knows is going to happen right because
gabe that is some of the most damning
evidence that is going to come out oh
yeah is is trump standing in a room with
someone who is not supposed to be
looking at these documents
and showing these documents to people
who are not supposed to see these
documents right i would imagine that
it's going to show even more blatant
crimes than that even and tucker carlson
believes that he knows that he knows
donald trump is a [ __ ] criminal the
guy hung out with him at bedminster i
would almost bet i would almost bet
money that tucker carlson has probably
been in the room and donald trump is
flashing this stuff at people that's the
other reason why tucker carlson's a
little nervous and the reason why he
might have took a vacation last week he
had to change his diapers because well i
think you know who knows maybe it wasn't
a vacation maybe he was consulting his
uh legal team he said guys look
there may or may not have been a
possibility of me viewing documents that
i may or may not have seen or should
have seen
and i may or may not have touched it
right and my fingerprints may or may not
have shown up on these documents that
the fbi is now scanning for so when you
look at this like you know we talked
about before and maybe i said on the
show but like i know after the
announcement happened of like oh you
know
18 months and now garland is moving
forward
the big question there is like okay what
took 18 months right that's the big
question ever so why would you know why
did it take so long right well obviously
it depends on when the investigation was
started and what they got kind of
whispers or or
or kind of hints at but the other part
was
i wouldn't be surprised if they had
someone on the inside that was able to
verify as a witness
under the direction of the doj or fbi to
say yep he showed those documents and
even more
i possibly wouldn't be surprised if they
sent someone in
and had it all recorded
so like oh show us that document oh yeah
i'll show you that document let me pull
down the box from melania's closet right
here we go boom look at this and he's
like you know taking a photo yeah take a
photo with take a selfie or whatever you
know uh but the idea that can you want
to take a picture with with me you and
the document we'll do a thumbs up we'll
do it all you know you and the
documentary pretend like you're ripping
up the document do one of those ones
we'll do that'll be hilarious that'd be
fun
i i have this very very
kind of strong feeling
that the doj and the fbi wouldn't act on
something again unless they had very
concrete evidence whether it was someone
that they sent in and they had an eye on
the situation but i also wouldn't be
surprised if they were like yeah we need
more than that because then it's just
hearsay we need to see this [ __ ] on
footage on camera
so go in there with a little like button
mic or lapel mic or whatever it is and
get that [ __ ] with him open opening the
box showing it off offering it to give
it to you taking a photo whatever i
think you're right i don't i think well
number one would you even would you even
take any kind of phone call whatsoever
no matter what the subject from donald
trump without recording that
[ __ ] number oh no i would be
like oh [ __ ] okay record boom take it
right yeah i'm definitely recording that
phone call but do you know how many
people are probably wearing wires and i
don't just mean like a wire for law
enforcement
you you got to know like if you're
within earshot of this [ __ ] and
you're having conversations and he's
going to blackmail you you better have
some kind of recording device on to
prove what this son of a [ __ ] said and
what he didn't say the other thing that
boggles my mind we said it yesterday
about this because tucker here is
talking about the closed-circuit
television which is they're security
cameras yeah right they're security
cameras inside and outside mar-a-lago
and inside and even the residence part
of it not just the business because
there is a business you know right but
we have you know a former president
residing in this
area right right so they have to have
footage which which he's he it's not
technically his full-time residence
because the
um isn't palm beach suing him because he
can't stay there full-time or some [ __ ]
yeah well they agree yeah there was the
whole thing and i don't know if that
case is still going i don't know but i
know that they were that's why he has to
go back to new jersey and he has to go
back to new york in new york every once
while because it's not his permanent he
can't live there permanently for for a
while but here's the thing
is
if he's everyone compares him to a
mobster and i call i call him the cheeto
dust mobster but i call that to mock him
because if he really is a mobster he is
the world's worst mobster to let
security cameras
[ __ ] record him committing crimes the
absolute security the dumbest [ __ ]
dumbest ever
dumbest idea is to i mean again we
compared it to yesterday like the scene
in goodfellas when ray leota uh uh uh
joe pesci and and robert de niro are are
um are opening up the trunk the very
first when he's talking about you know
and before he goes into why he's a
mobster they open up the scene you'll be
like well before we open this up why
don't you turn your camera on so that
way we can record what's about to happen
yeah right like what are you talking
about no no no [ __ ] good mobster
would want to record themselves doing
crimes but trump trump has been doing it
they know they've been doing it and here
let's finish tucker here talking about
how gaslighting his audience and
preparing his audience for the world's
worst situation which is donald trump
really
on the server remember the endless
russia collusion hoax we're in for a lot
more of that they'll scream at how trump
is a criminal and if you express any
support for him or any interest in
retaining i don't know the rights of
free speech and due process you're a
criminal too in fact you are the threat
you're the threat and just mentioning
that you disagree with what is happening
is an attack on our government
so what he's saying is is that if you
voice
and support allies which are blatant
lies
then you're a criminal and that's not
what anyone's saying i don't actually
think we should we should stifle
anyone's speech really honestly it's
kind of like at this point in our
society
when they say stupid [ __ ] like this it's
it's it's almost like they're wearing a
stupid shirt right like i'm i'm really
it's just an arrow pointing back at
themselves i'm almost stupid and the
arrow points up to them like literally
this
this freedom of speech thing actually is
our
greatest asset because it exposes
the dumbest of the dumbest here and the
people who actually are [ __ ]
completely diluted and you can stay away
from them in the grocery store if you
want to but let's listen to how tucker
frames up that
that that the non-fascists the people
who are trying to fight the fascists are
the fascist here their style just the
other day after signing off in the
mar-a-lago raid your attorney general
merrick garland came on stage to whine
about how actually he was the victim
here he's the victim
apparently some people disagreed with
the raid so the fbi the most heavily
armed domestic law enforcement agency in
the world
why wouldn't why wouldn't the fbi be
armed
yeah so they're going from now
now now it's it's egregious because i
think trump even posted this in one of
his fraud social posts about about the
um
guns to the hilt or some [ __ ] or we said
gun toting go gun toad now gun toting
and people having guns is bad i don't
understand what it it they tying
themselves in the pretzels is now under
threat
from you
right you're the criminal our critics
are in jail but i got anonymous threats
on twitter poor me
passive aggression is the defining
characteristic of the left
if they started putting people in camps
nbc news would cheer them on and then
attack you for complaining about it how
dare you
violating our norms we've always had
camps
what the [ __ ] is he talking about like
he literally he really is projecting
right tucker wants camps this is
absolutely [ __ ] tucker camperson that
is what he is that's what he is tucker
camperson
one wants camps he loves camps he
only knows the best camps just like
donald trump
well and donald trump jr yeah yeah this
is the one last video i want to play it
says complete freak out you posted this
video on twitter because apparently
donald trump has broke his silence over
on facebook finally where he posted i
have been ever since how long was this
how long was the whole video
uh it's like three minutes and
not two it's not too long because then i
normally do like eight or nine minutes
of this [ __ ] no well not normally i mean
he'll go on a rant for sure and this was
a rant uh but sometimes he can like keep
it you know moving or whatever but at
the end of the day like this video
i texted you the day that this [ __ ]
uh search happened and i was like i'm
waiting i am waiting for the video that
donald trump jr does and it did not
disappoint well i tell you as soon as i
as soon as i found it and it was a few
minutes after i guess it was posted i
sent it to you i was like hey
dude dude's freaking out on facebook
and here's the thing here's what i said
about i have a lot of questions by the
way a lot of things in the background
right someone talked about yeah i don't
know what the [ __ ] that is i said dude
still has the butt plug bong
on the bookshelf like look at this what
the [ __ ] and i i guarantee you for a
while i guarantee he bought that flag
from someone like disrespectful yeah he
bought that flag absolutely because uh
uh junior bone spurs junior has never
had anyone in his family in the military
for that matter so but let's listen
let's listen to the freak out from
donald trump jr and he's trying to get
daddy's attention here is what i believe
it is but let's watch chris reyes head
hunter biden's laptop for three years
okay james comey i didn't do anything
with hillary clinton and 30 000 emails
literally taking hammers to their phones
under subpoena no big deal you know
there's some stuff there he said but
like i don't know we wouldn't want to
politicize it and yet strangely enough
they had no problems uh raiding two
trump lawyers uh going after peter
navarro a trump advisor in the white
house and putting him in leg shackles
showing up to roger stone's house with
17
vehicles apparently according to roger
stone and armed fbi agents for a 70 year
old dude that would have come in
willingly
uh my father says that he would have
given them what they wanted had they
done this but no they needed the fbi
hostage rescue team the hrt
oh my
god this guy
this guy okay so here's what i hunt your
bed in your bed
chris ray chris ratcher stone he always
does this with names why is it what did
he do he's like roger stone a 7 year 70
year old man who would have gone in
willingly [ __ ] you know he would holy
[ __ ] listen here's what i'll tell you
about this
i think that the fbi agents got that
industrial size bottle of adderall and
it really it really stopped the flow of
adderall to donald trump jr and he
finally he finally got his supply back
on track and that is why we have this
video that is why we have this video
so i i think it's a treasure i think
it's a beautiful thing that he's uh
they're in full freakout mode you know
what we should do we should lift that
entire video and put it on our youtube
channel yeah maybe we'll do like a
review of it or something yeah and put
it on the youtube channel maybe we'll do
that this afternoon we should do that we
should watch the entire video do a
review of it we'll post it for you guys
on the youtube channel so subscribe to
the youtube channel the tony michaels
podcast don't forget to also go over to
twitter and follow at tony michael's pod
you don't want to miss a thing on
twitter i'm sure i'm sure gabe that that
um that fbi unboxing video end up
somewhere on twitter yeah you might
wanna you might wanna follow at i am
gabe sanchez and me at the johnny
michaels too you might wanna follow us
as well go ahead and download every
single episode on your favorite
directory apple spotify google make sure
to leave us a great review while you're
there and listen it's okay if you go
over there and you play it play each
episode to listen for a little bit it
helps us out over there and boy is our
audience really kicking in game this
thing is taken off like a [ __ ] rocket
like it's taking off like donald trump
jr on coke
[Music]
coke field donald trump
jr
that bro i can't tell if he's if it you
know at the end of the day i can't tell
if his beard is turning great or if it's
just a remnants of coke from a lion it
is kind of confusing isn't it it is kind
of confusing but you know a lot of
treason and espionage will do that to a
guy it will so will so will a ton of
hatred yeah that will really [ __ ]
yeah that'll be a racist or you have
hatred or bigotry it'll age you like a
[ __ ] like a [ __ ]
everyone speaking of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
do not do not miss a single episode of
the tony michaels podcast we broadcast
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central ninth pacific for two full hours
here on youtube twitter and twitch we
also simulcast from the midas touch
facebook page i think we're going to do
this don junior video we have to do this
we have yeah yeah i mean there's a
facetime call coming don't worry that's
great
well let's let's pull that video let's
review it let's put it up on youtube
everyone make sure to subscribe to the
tony michaels podcast until tomorrow you
gotta come back you gotta come back and
watch same time same place
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking